hey guys welcome back to your brandy we
were back on Monster Hunter world again
and today is the official release day of
the summer festival so I didn't want to
give you guys a quick video on how to
get these summer insect field guides as
fast as possible as it and get some of
the new armor for this event festival so
the first thing you want to be doing is
doing the arena quest called Gajuwaka
outbreak recently just killed 810
Gajuwaka i'm pretty sure i butchered
that name i do apologize if I did if I
didn't that's great but either way this
is one of those times challenge quests
so getting an a-rank and this will give
you three tickets b-rank will give you
two tickets and c will give you one this
shouldn't really be too difficult since
it's just Gajuwaka
even though there is a barrel fighting
you when you do this but he really isn't
that hard to move away from this is one
of those challenge quests you are going
to have to be getting a preset build I
happen to pick the heavy bow gun except
I'm really garbage with ranged weapon so
I kind of got kicked around by Bharath
alot but still I managed to get this and
I'm probably about 2 or 3 minutes which
isn't too bad at the time but for this
you're going to be getting access to the
butterfly set of course you're not just
going to be in the summer insights field
guide you're going to be needing a
couple more items but that is the main
item that you're going to be needing to
craft this set now it's not really too
crazy of an armor set it does come with
stun resistance level 3 defense level 3
health boost level 3 critical eye level
3 marathon runner 3 and pearl longer
level 2 so it's got decent perks but as
they set together I wouldn't really run
it myself and it also is pretty low on
the very list I believe a rarity 5 or 4
so it really won't help you in big
fights at all
but it's maybe one of those random sets
that you might just want to incorporate
into your build so maybe it fits for you
maybe it doesn't it's entirely up to you
Vega is going to be really quick video
how to get these summer insects field
guides really quickly so with that like
the B if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new I covered these solo guides a
monster on a world as well as the event
quest for the summer festival spring
festival I did all those types and as
well the weekly ones that come up just
to let everybody know which ones you
should be keeping track of and all that
good stuff I mean that guy's my two most
recent videos would be on the screen if
you guys wanna check that out and thank
you guys for watching the video peace
out